hello everyone
welcome to one of the last sessions here
at ndc i hope you had
a good time the last days it's for me
it's really great to be back in
in-person events after talking two years
with the monitor
and yeah i hope you enjoyed it
i want to talk with you about security
and
the thing if we talk about security
is normally that everybody has this
completely wrong picture in mind right
so uh from the movies we see everybody
sees one that is hacking like crazy at
this keyboard and trying to attack a
firewall and the problem is this is not
real life like you're all developers you
know that nobody of you writes code like
hackers in the movies are trying to
brute force uh i don't know a firewall
so in real life hacking is completely
different and while people think it
works like this normally the hacker
probably is calling your mother and
trying to convince her to tell her how
your first pet was named to reset a
password from you right or you're
clicking on facebook on some tests and
provide personal data that helps people
to find other attack vectors and what i
want to do is like i want to shift a
little bit the discussion about security
for developers because a lot of
developers i talked to they're like nah
security's i don't know not for me and
i'm an expert and everything is safe
here and i want to shift a little bit to
security and make clear that we're all
affected and we are one of the main
attack vectors right now are developers
development environments and our
applications and we as developers we are
responsible for that
of course everybody right now always
talks about uh uh lock for jay and and a
lot of the things but i wanna
tell another story a much simpler story
and much easier to understand but it's a
really great story because it shows
how attacks today can occur right
and
the attack i want to talk about is event
stream and event stream is is such a
good example because it contains all
facets of a supply chain attack right it
starts with social engineering a new
contributor to open source project
worked with them helped out and finally
gained access to the repository and
could push code
and you have to know event stream is a
very popular npm package on github that
is used in a lot of libraries and one of
them is
copy and copy is an open source bitcoin
wallet
and copper uses event stream so this one
user took some time contributed worked
with them until he finally got the trust
and got commit message commit rights to
the repository and what he did he
introduced a new dependency to
flatmap stream and flatmap stream was a
very simple
package it was uh
had a one committer and only one file so
it was a little bit suspicious but no
malicious code and people were talking
about why are you adding this dependency
and he just removed it and upgraded to a
new major version version 4.
but of course copy did not update to a
major version so soon so there are still
a lot of applications out there that
were using the version 3 and then he
introduced a malicious version of flat
screen map and that of course got
published out to all the versions that
had three
three point something installed
and
what the vulnerable code would do what
it was just check if you're a copy user
more or less so it was a direct attack
on copy but using flatmate stream to get
to event stream and using social
engineering to to get into the
repository and getting rights and
so the vulnerable code would just check
if you're a copper user and if you would
have more than i think 1 100 i don't
know bitcoins 100 it would just harvest
the bitcoins upload your code and
everything to a control server
and you can imagine 100 bitcoins it's
quite a money so you can really spend
some time social engineering for this
kind of money if such an attack is
successful and this shows us a little
bit how we have to
approach security today it's not just
okay to have a firewall it's not just
okay to do a security review afterwards
we really have to be aware that security
is everywhere in our development process
from the developer development
environment the source code itself the
build environment packaging deploying
and let's
at last step the consumer and of course
all the dependencies they're all
vulnerable they contain all
vulnerabilities and the vulnerability
might only be there in a very short time
so that it's really easy to hide it from
the normal developer
and of course all these dependencies
have more dependencies and they have
more dependencies and no they have more
dependencies this is for just a small
part of all the dependencies in gatsby's
and of course all of these dependencies
um
have the same attack vectors right they
all have environment built environments
they all have developers they all have
build systems so this is like a
recursion here and a lot of
attack surface that can that attackers
can use to really get into your
application
and if we look at
the losses we had over the last years so
last year we had 6.9 million
losses caused by cyber attacks so this
is really
a big trouble and this is only the the
losses that are reported to ic3 right so
this is uh the the real number and the
worldwide number is much much higher
just to give you give you an idea where
we are
and
of course the earlier you find the
vulnerability in your code the more
secure you are so if
the more cheaper it is sorry so if
you fix a bug a security bug while
you're developing and it's cheap right
it's just fixing the buck if it's once
deployed to an environment it gets much
more expensive and if it's once in
production and you're you're breached
then
the loss is millions so so the earlier
you catch it the cheaper it is so that's
why we say we try to shift left security
and integrate it in the process as early
as possible
so
i want to go with you now through all
the attack vectors in such a software
supply chain or in your development
chain and then just have a look at each
one of them
the first attack vector is
you the developer and the developer is a
really good attack vector right because
probably you think hey what what can go
wrong i'm just a developer i'm just a
normal employee but normally with admin
rights to a lot of systems with
admin rights to a very powerful local
machine with a ton of tools installed
that really help if an attacker is
already
there
um
you can modify code you can execute
scripts during the pipeline so it's a
developer is basically yeah it's not
maybe not as good as an administrator
but really close to it so you're a
really powerful
tool in an attack chain i would say
right and this is something you have to
be aware of as a developer
or for example unsecured connections to
test system a lot of my customers they
still have web servers in-house that are
not secured and they have basic
authentication and they send credentials
to him and they say yeah we have the
production that is secure but here in
the network it's not so
difficult so people can fish it so a lot
of attack vectors around the developer
themselves
one of the biggest is fishing
phishing is still one of the biggest
yeah the most common
attacks at all
and you can see here to fishing males
one of them is a real one is a
simulation with it at the company
and
a lot of people think yeah i know
fishing i'm an engineer so this does not
affect me but what people often forget
is that people are primed right the more
the attacker knows about you the easier
is it to give you a phishing mail that
you fall for
an example
you log in every morning at 9 o'clock
because at nine o'clock everybody starts
working right so everybody goes into the
building at nine so you as an attacker
you send a phishing mail at nine at ten
minutes past nine because this is
probably the time that people are
logging on if you get a phishing mail
that like says okay you have to verify
your logging or something and it's just
you're in the logging process you're
just primed you don't look so carefully
if this is a phishing mail or not
because they think oh i'm logging in
okay
extra security measure when you click on
it or if you get paid every first of the
month we will send you this day and mail
that says hey there was something wrong
with your payment please click urgent
here so that we can fix it and there's
some urgency you're calculating with it
oh today's the day and that's why you're
primed and you would click on it and had
a lot of colleagues that were like ah
i don't know phishing simulations i
don't need this we're all experts and
in one or two years like everybody of
them clicked once on one right so maybe
they did not enter the password but if
you have a malicious attachment that's
enough right if you have a malicious
website a click might be enough and also
i clicked on once uh because it was just
priming i was uh yeah thinking about it
flip click so
fishing is still one of the main
or the easiest entries into your
network
so what can you do if you have
credentials of a developer
right you can for example
spare fish other people right so and
this is also an aspect from fishing
fishing can be of course from them from
an anonymous address but if you once
have leaked one in your company you can
spare fish someone else for example if
the fishing males is like this previous
one here it's obvious but if
for example
a guy at the at the at an entry desk in
your company gets breached and he sends
you a phishing mail then it's much more
secure but it's probably not from an
external address and people will click
on it and it's if you as a developer
send an email to an admin
the chance that he clicks on it it will
be pretty good because he said hey it's
another engineer i will probably click
on it right so spare ship fishing is a
very powerful tool here to get from one
victim to the next one
mimi cuts so if you have as a developer
login rights to a lot of machines
test machines developer machines build
machines people can log on and if your
local admin you can run mini cuts and
mini cuts will display you a lot of
secrets from a lot of users on that
machine
and a lot of people
don't think about this right so the
passwords are somehow in memory and you
can read them a lot of them
you can inject source code so for most
systems one line of source code is
enough to to disable all authentication
so modify source code or if you can
modify the pipelines or run pipelines
you can inject scripts or code and
execute it in different environments
and yeah if you have
access to test environments you can log
into the test and mines and look okay do
for example prod admins login here
because we have the same admin accounts
for plot and test then you can mimi cuts
and get their credentials
or
yeah other for example do we test broad
do we have credentials here that go
against broad and we can try to read
them
and of course if you're developing you
have access to broad and i see that a
lot
it's game over anyway right so then yeah
you're done
yeah but these are the obvious things
but there are also a lot of other things
that people don't think of for example
typo squatting
so what is typo squatting
if you run npm install cross-end
then
this will steal all your environment
variables and send them up to a control
server
if you install and click npio if you
type npm install cross minus n this is
the real package what you want to
install in reality so this small typo
will send all your environment variables
up and you probably have some secrets
there because you're testing
some apis so the attacker has your
secrets
or namespace shadowing
if you install npm install add azure
call tracing then you have the real
package but if you just do an npm
install called tracing it will also
upload your data to your server
and this is something you have to be
aware of because these are really
powerful attacks and the packages often
hide themselves and then
so so it has different attack vectors
right so it can attack you right away
and send all your data to the cloud or
to a control server
or
it can just shadow the other component
and then just behave like the normal
component and you probably will not
realize it if you if you're not checking
and you ship it and then the attacker
can also attack your application at
runtime
so it's a really
interesting
way now to attack developers
so what can you do
um of course uh security awareness
trainings yeah bringing a security
culture yeah
people that say uh or have
uh doubts about something and then care
about security they should not be there
he's always
so so you have to really allow this and
create a culture of security and the
best thing is creating awareness
training
and there are some security games that
you can in
integrate into your sprint practices
right so every end of the sprint you do
like a 10-minute 15-minute game it
doesn't have to be a big thing it's just
to be something that should be
always present to have all the awareness
from the developers that security is not
someone else's
topic but it's it's we developers that
we have to make sure that our
applications are safe and not only on
our dev machine but also on test systems
on production
it's all
yeah devops it's our process it's our
application it's our responsibility to
make it secure
red team blue team simulations
i don't know if you do this
only a few companies i know do it so you
can also do like simulations where you
simulate an attack maybe with some
external company and you simulate it and
you can be part of the red team or the
blue team red team attacks blue team try
to defend
so this really gets up the awareness
from people that oh this is maybe easier
to attack than i thought and brings the
awareness to the developers
and of course make sure to have
ephemeral containerized environments for
builds for development and for
everything that if you for example type
of squatting it's not get having admin
access to one of your machines in your
network right if you're in a
containerized development environment or
build environment or something it's more
secure and has not asked me any admin
access and can get credentials from
other people or other credentials from
yourself
development environment so what can i do
with the development environment there
are passwords normally in text files in
the environment variables
you can mini cuts and read all kinds of
secrets you can modify build tools and
attach to it to to hack into the build
process and then attaching um yeah
vulnerable code to your actual code yeah
like in the sonar window tech
and yeah of course you can modify code
that might get shipped or get committed
without
the developer knowing it and you can
modify pipelines and execute code
so
this is what credentials in plain text
files look like and if a developer says
i've never done that i think he's lying
or i don't know he's just working on
public things right i did it a lot
because if you do end to end test if you
want to automate you will need some
credentials somewhere and at least at
the development environment you have
them somewhere in plain text
in your as an environment variable or in
some code files
other examples for credentials and test
files so i some colleagues and i said
okay
give me real world examples and that's
what they send me so it doesn't matter
if it's a token auth token user password
you will have credentials in text files
living in your development environment
and this is an example of a project for
me open source project quite old and of
course this does not contain
a password but you can search for it on
github and if you find this on github
and you know someone is using this
package you are not you know for sure
that on the development environment you
will find a copy of this file that
contains the password right so
even by inspecting public packages on
github the source code you can find
some indicators that tells you if
somebody uses this package he might have
a file somewhere that has credentials in
plain text that you can read
unsecured file shares yeah also
it happens less now we have unsecured
sharepoint
um shares but it's more or less the same
right somehow developers share things um
they they they have the files they share
together and if you scan for open file
shares you still find a lot at our
customers
mini cuts
so i don't know if you ever executed it
on your windows machine if you have a
newer windows 10 it's protected so
your your actual password cannot be read
if you have an older one it can
but besides your normal windows password
you get a lot of other informations for
example all our tokens
that are in memory and that are
currently used i had for example here
office 365 my github
key here that you can read in in plain
text
here gitlab github
a lot of tokens you can find out with me
with
mini cuts and not only for yourself but
for other developers right so at the
moment or for the users at the pc so the
moment you can to log into a development
environment you can see who else is
logging in here and if it's an admin or
something you might get the credentials
of the administrator
so here's an example how an attack could
work right you look
you find an unsecured file share you
find a test credential that has access
to a dev machine you access the dev
machine your mimi cuts and then you have
the developer credentials and then you
can commit code you can
execute a pipeline a lot of
possibilities from there
spearfish other people
so once you have one
victim i would say one credentials that
you can use to log in to a machine yeah
then you can just find your way
to production by using different tools
for example plus sound so bloodhound is
a tool that you can run and it analyzes
all your active directory traffic in
your network and builds these graphs for
you that help you see okay how do i come
from dev to broad
and
of course there are other tools yeah but
there's one and here's an example how a
chain
looks like right so you have a test
account for example in your domain a
test account
you can log on a development machine
where developer
is active and you can mimic cuts the
credentials the developer might have
access to a test environment on the test
environment there is
an admin
so you have admin right there
mini cuts and then you are at production
this is just an example but this is why
we have to be very careful with being
like the entry point and as developers
we are under attack we have type of
spotting and things like that so we have
to be aware to not be here the entry
point for people to get to broad
and it's basically um
yeah michael
v hayden that said
fundamentally if somebody wants to get
in they are getting in
all right accept it it's like this and
uh we call this the assume breach
paradigm right
it's
in the past we always said okay let's
prevent breach let's have firewalls
let's have a vpn be secure but but
inside this perimeter in these layers we
are secure and we can do what we want
but with the assume breach paradigm we
say okay we are not secure in the
perimeters right we always have to
assume we are already preached someone
is already in there i don't know if it's
a developer i don't know if it's the
admin i don't know if the service desk
guy somebody might be in there so we
have to
um keep it zero trust we don't trust
anybody so we meaning we have to enforce
multi-factor authentication secure
socket layer for all servers even
internal test systems right
we have to separate our accounts and not
log into a test
test machine with our production
credentials right so we have to separate
the domains that if someone
breaches this machine he does not get
the main admin credentials for example
on these privileges that you only use
user accounts or the
the permissions that you need in that
moment to fulfill the task that you're
doing that you're not for example as a
developer work all day long as
administrators so who's working as a
local administrator
that's good
one year ago i think it was 90 people
raising their hand and say i'm a
developer i have to work as a local
admin
and
it's good to see that it's getting less
yeah
so what to do
i think a really important part is
having digital development environments
yeah having environments where people
are not administrator but still can do
their work
um
ideally so this can be a virtual desktop
or something that's fine but ideally
it's specific to the project right for
example github code spaces if you have
github code spaces you have one virtual
development environment for each project
and you can pre
pre-compile the images so you can spin
up a new image in seconds so github is
using codespaces themselves so they have
brought down their the setup for their
development environments for
days
if not weeks to a few seconds right so
they they had everything on the mac
before and now they have code spaces
they have pre-compiled images they have
the code installed for hand and and they
spin up very fast so a new employee can
just get in spin up a code space and can
start coding and in a secure way because
he's not locked in there he does not his
emails there so
the whole deaf environment has far less
attack vectors than a local machine with
probably admin rights
and of course don't have local admin
rights so i think a lot of people don't
yeah but
you don't have it as an administrator
you should not have it as an uh
developer only if you need it and you
shouldn't need it if you need it go to
virtual environment and create it there
specific for this case
and of course secret scanning
there are a lot of secret scanning tools
um
depending on the file share you can
dumpster or you can bash script it
yourself
using some regular expression you have
git leaks
spectral orbs a lot of things that you
can integrate and get and github secret
scanning is very powerful if you're
using github
for public repositories is for free it's
in there anyway so you don't have to do
anything for private it's part of the
advanced security and github is
partnering with i don't know 70 people
70 partners right now and it's detecting
secrets for them and if you're using
github you will see that every secret
they have has a prefix it's always like
gh
a or whatever secret it is so that git
so that it's easier for secret scanning
to detect and a lot of partners also do
this right amazon
microsoft azure
all the secrets they have some prefix so
it's easier to detect that it's a secret
github will prevent you from pushing
this so it will if you have push
protection on it will prevent you from
pushing it will send you a url you can
open it and then say okay i want to push
anyway it's a false positive or
something and then you still can commit
and github at the back end will send the
uh
the secret to the partner to verify that
it's not a full positive that is there
and then the partner can decide what to
do with it
revoke it
rotate it or does nothing just inform
you that you have leaked a secret
somewhere
but secret scanning is a really
important part to not have secrets lying
around in code in file systems and
anywhere
attack vector supply chain so your
supply chain is not only your packages
right so your blockchain
is also all the software that you use to
build your software right npm ci dot net
cli terraform all the other tools you
have in your build system so all
tools involved in building your software
are also part of the supply chain and
then of course your deep dependency tree
under all the libraries you depend upon
and the libraries they depend upon and
so on and so forth
so what to do you have to know your
dependencies
in 2016 one library nearly broke the
internet so you could really note that
day that something was off
and it was due to a small library called
pet left no left pet
a left pet was a small library with 11
lines of code and it did nothing but
adding a character before a string and
filling it out with blanks about
something else
so
this 11 line of code every java script
developer should be able to write on the
on their own
right but there was a dependency
not directly in react but in one of the
packages that was used by react and so
this dependency made it into react
and other big libraries
and there was a naming conflict because
this
package belonged to a contributor that
had another package that was called kik
and the messenger kik they also wanted
to create a library and we're saying hey
we want this name and so they had this
dispute with the
open source contributor with npm and
during the dispute the contributor just
revoked all its packages and not just a
kick but also everything
one of them left pet and this basically
made this day react applications not
built so it nearly broke the internet
right
so you should be aware of all your
dependencies and what dependencies they
have and
i saw another talk here i think these
days it said okay there's also package
that says is is even or is odd so
they're really javascript packages is
even right every developer should be
able to write this on their own without
depending on our packages so really be
careful what dependencies you hold you
get into your code because you never
know when they go when they break or if
they have vulnerabilities
so what can we do software composition
analysis sca a software composition
analysis um goes through your dependency
trees and analyzes this and and and
gives you yeah information about license
compliance about found vulnerabilities
and gives you insights and then allows
you to manage or yeah control
and manage your dependency tree yeah
yeah there are different tools
dependency track and core github
dependency management so again in open
source this is free and just in the
product you can just use it under the
inside stub you can find all your
dependencies and dependencies are not
only a package.json right so also github
actions is a dependency git submits are
dependencies so a lot of dependencies
are supported here and you can analyze
them and help you
monitor and get a glimpse of what you're
depending on
so
there are two frameworks that help you
um with um yeah supply chain security
so um
one is called salsa so this is the newer
one it's still in in an early alpha
and one is scvs from uvasp and they're
basically frameworks that help you to to
like a maturity matrix to go through all
your inventory process right so
inventory software bill of materials
built environments package management
and
check if you're
yeah if you have problems at that area
so i'm not going all of this right now
because this is a talk for each topic of
their own right
but this is something you can be aware
of i just want to highlight one and this
is the bills of material
yeah and software bills of material is
an interesting topic right now because
it's like demanded from from
from u.s government
but they're still
different standards and none of the
standards is really
i don't know i would say everywhere so
it's still a very fluctuating topic
and uh yeah so what is a bit of material
so if you buy a machine today you will
get a bill of material and the bill of
material contains all the components
that make up your product you buy so you
can really go back if you have a problem
and a part is missing or something you
say okay this is the part with that
version i ordered at that day
right
and the same is here for software right
so
it's a standard that is requested as a
okay we need a software bill of material
that tells us exactly what version we
built the software with
and right now we have different
standards for example the software
package data exchange spdx that is used
from swift and encore
and we have
cyclone dx this is the overs package
and there's an older one that are
software identification text suite that
are more used in software asset
management and they are like sub
standards for the others so so cyclone
dx or spdx they both can use swift tags
if software are provided to switch but
swifttech is not really so important
right now if you want to go and and to
do sbom i would say spdx and cdx are the
more mature versions
yeah but it's just just a topic that you
probably will her will hear of if you
talk about supply chain security right
now
and it's a good topic but i still think
it's not there yet to be 100
used because it also only contains the
software tools right it doesn't contain
for example the build environment if you
use
an ephemeral environment and you have
documented and logged everything there
it's not necessary but this should also
be part of the
software builds of material right okay
what server did it build on what two is
where installed and uh because this can
all affect the build process so it
should be included and i think there's
no solution yet available for that
so what to do you should know your
dependencies
and you should keep them up to date
and you should again use ephemeral build
environments and development
environments uh that are specific this
will help you like if you preach like
yeah making sure it keeps stays there
and yeah knowing your dependencies
um use software composition analysis and
for example if you're on github you can
use the penderbot and enable it and this
will allow you or this will help you
keeping it up to date so if a
vulnerability is found they will
directly create a put request for you so
that you can just see what has changed
and you just have to approve if you have
a build it will run automatically your
tests and then you can easily merge the
fix into your repository so it's just
one click more or less to update your
dependencies especially if they have a
vulnerability but you can also use it to
update every dependency to normal
versions if you want
so and this is something you really
should think about because updating all
the packages in this big dependency tree
is a lot of work and the more you
automate here the better and the higher
the chance that your components are up
to date
and a big percentage of the
vulnerabilities is still because
packages are not patched because people
are just too lazy they want to go into
patch too many
versions here then one is failing and
then people just let it so find a
process automate what you can for
example just approve
patches or security updates and only
have manual approvals for minor and
major versions or something like that
but this is really an area where you
should invest keeping your entire
supply chain up to date
vulnerabilities so of course now we are
at the application in the heart of the
application
you probably know the uber's top 10.
i think i know there was another talk
the other day here um where they had
their overs top 10 in-depth so these are
the new top 10 of um yeah attack vectors
to the applications so number one still
broken access control
uh cryptographic failures and number
three injection so one of the most
uh critical things is still injection
and i'm not going through the overstep
10 because this is again is a topic for
an entire talk on their own but i want
to highlight injection
so
94 of the applications tested for
injection um
had an incident rate of 19
so
yeah max incident rate of 90 on average
with three percent um so it's still a
very important attack vector for your
application and if we look what common
vulnerability enumerators belong to
injections so this is cross-site
scripting sql injection and external
control of a file name or path
and
i don't know if you're aware of sql
injection but you should as a developer
what is sql injection well someone
bringing user code to your database and
executing it for example modifying the
string and you're not
sanitizing the string i would say okay
you have to sanitize every user input
and this gives the people ability to
execute sql
by entering modified strings
this is another example for cross-site
scripting
so you should be aware of this kind of
attacks and you should put measures in
place because of course as experienced
developers with a lot of years you
probably know this and these are
errors you're not committing but you
always have to think there are new
developers coming and you might not spot
it they modify something you don't
realize it and and you'll be vulnerable
also there are of course these are the
obvious ones right so but they're also
um sometimes attacked that are not so
easy to spot so it's not obvious you
just have forgot to sanitize the string
but you can modify
for example log4j right you can modify
it away in a string that that it was
interpreted by a package and modified
and then passed on so it's really
you have to be aware of them and put in
place things
to shift left security and to
automatically check for this kind of
vulnerabilities
and we call this static application
security testing right so
code analysis we analyze the code this
is um this is white white box testing
right so for example github code
analysis or sonar cube sam grab
different tools with different
capabilities and what they're doing is
they're analyzing your code to to find
vulnerabilities in
your code path
and for example code ql from github
advanced security
so they bought semi a few years ago you
might remember and what codeql does it
it generates a database from your code
so actually multiple databases but it
takes your code it generates a database
and then you have the code queries
they're open source they're in github
you can have a look at them and
the queries are basically like a query
language so you have a source user input
database field something and you have a
sync
execute something write it to the
database and then the query checks if
you have a match and the source matches
the thing and that's because the
database knows how your data flows
through your application right so it's
not just a static analysis where it
looks at the code and the function how
it looks it really knows that the user
input here is passed in this object here
it's assigned to this variable here it's
assigned here and it really knows how
your data flows to the entire
application
so this is a really powerful tool that
can help you
find vulnerabilities early
yep
thank you
so
static application security testing
is really a
big improvement if you integrate it in
your pipelines and then execute it as
often as possible
and it's important that you you're not
only executing it if you change code
because in the background there might be
new queries right so you should also
have a timed
execution that executes it from time to
time because if there are new queries on
a new vulnerability is found they write
a query for it then you should execute
this on your code even if nothing
changed so if you change your code base
daily it doesn't matter if you have code
bases that you change only a few times a
week or a month then it's good to have
it executed on a regular basis to find
something
dynamic application security testing so
of course there's a big gray area
between static and dynamic application
security testing because a lot of times
you still compile the code to do the
static analysis but normally dynamic
execute dynamic application security
testing is considered like black box
testing right so you have the
application you run it and you take it
from outside without insights of the
application how they work for example
uh what's separate proxy
so um
tap you can uh it's it's a standalone
application that pen testers normally
use and
i highly encourage you as a developer to
try it out once because it really gives
you a glimpse how to do it you can just
run and your web application you get
this heads-up display and then you can
start i don't know trying trying things
but you can also have just this the the
the spider and included in your pipeline
and have the sub spider running against
your web application and and like doing
all kind of attacks like from
the perspective of a running web
application in production right and if
you include it in the pipelines you get
earlier feedback if something is wrong
or something is broken for example
someone modified code and disable
something then you will find it here
quite early
yeah so this is what the report looks
like but it's really easy to include it
in your pipeline because black box
testing does not have a lot of variables
right so you can just execute it you
give it the target url and it runs but
of course this is just for web
application if you want to do this with
other kinds of application gets much
more complicated
infrastructure scanning
so
the more infrastructure is code we have
in our repositories
it's a good thing right but we still
have to ensure that the infrastructure
is secure so
what you should do is integr integrate
container scanning or infrastructure
structure scanning into your pipelines
to get early feedback to ensure that the
policies are right right
the different tools available like
encore gripe clear
or commercial like white source in agua
and
yeah this really helps you if you
integrate it in your in your pipeline to
validate if you have misconfiguration in
your infrastructure's code files
for example check off i really like
chekov if you never tried it it's an
open source tool it has more than one
thousand rules available for a lot of
aws for azure and you can just run it
against your infrastructure
infrastructure as code
files and you get a lot of warnings
right so okay s3 bucket should not be
public and a lot of best practices it
will discover out of the box without
modifying any of the rules of course
it's extensible you can write your own
rules and extend it but
also just using the default gives you
really much confidence
much more confidence if you're deploying
with infrastructure's code
yeah what to do so
make sure to shift left and include sus
and dust in your pipelines and execute
it regularly
make sure you have infrastructure
scanning and policies in place to check
that your infrastructure as code is
secure
and yeah in general um shift that
security and yeah also include code
spaces
i think
they're wrong they shouldn't be here on
that slide
so let's
stop by shift left security
yeah one information one important uh
last point
so now we've seen all the
attack vectors during your development
life cycle and make sure you have one
security and information event
management that locks all these events
from all tools right all your sas tools
das tools um secret scanning code
scanning and all your built events that
are cure make sure to lock them into one
central security system so that your
your sock center can easily monitor it
right
see a lot of
a lot of environments to forget it they
have to build environments test
environment and and sock and this is
only production right and the other
thing is out and
with the supply chain we have to make
sure that the entire development supply
chain here is also monitored is also
part of the security monitoring
so here um reference to web book from
microsoft with some
tips on
securing your
devops practices right so first thing
build a security first culture
yeah make security part of your devops
team and not just
of some
checks that are when when it's already
too late and your application is built
so so make it really part of your uh
your pi of your culture of your teams
and then make it a first priority for
everyone
integrated in the early stages of the
development life cycle right you're as a
developer you have to care about
security not someone else that is later
on
monitor and observe continuously with
purpose and monitor and absorb
everything right not just
production embrace everything is code
config is code infrastructure is code
it's much secure than just doing these
things manually
realize compliance with policies and
then secure and visualize your software
supply chain and this is one of the
biggest
attack vectors right now
some dependency in your pipeline because
it's really hard to control all of them
so i hope i could shift a little bit uh
the discussion and uh especially create
awareness for security
um of course all these topics are this
is very high level here but i think it's
really important because a lot of
developers
i don't know a little bit
fear of of contacting security because
it's a complicated topic and i think
it's important to see that
in your everyday life it's not a pain
right if you have good secret scanning
code scanning
if everything is just implemented in
your pipeline then it's easy and it
should not
hurt you yeah it just you should have
the awareness and you should integrate
in your teams regular regular
yeah habits like like security games
being aware of it and really integrate
it and make it part of your integral
yeah process and your culture
okay
with that uh yeah thank you very much
and if you have any questions
feel free to
ask them
you